Mr. Rishi
seems to have made good use of his precious time.Where on
earth did Arnold learn that solidity?It's a secret.Also, it's not worthy of
your praise.It's
obvious that Geki has cut corners.
Hey, who are you? Stay away from Rishi! I can't let
you all stay as you are and stand up against the country's changing eyes. You're a
monster messenger who annihilated the enemy's knights with just one servant. Stop it.  You too
will be killed.Even
if I visit Arnold, he won't just draw his sword.Ah, the
man who killed me in my 6th life.One day, this person will start a war that will involve the entire world.
What are you doing in the war [music] that caused you to lose your life? I
apologize for the sudden change in tone and ask you to
be my wife.